so you know how a Chinese is just
picture writing alright there's more to
this story like all of the world's
earliest writing systems Chinese
characters start out as symbols that
stand for words a rice paddy a person a
tree
these are logographs and they let you
depict specific language pieces to write
what you mean but instead of requiring
different characters for every word the
handy rebus principle lets you write
other things that sound like the
logograph to write what you say sure you
could use the rebus sounds like
principle to write any sound in your
language but please consider this symbol
and answer the question that follows
does it mean son soon son or sone oh my
did rebus writing get you into a bit of
trouble here when we see this character
we could read it as a plain old
logograph according to its meaning or
any of these rebus ways following its
pronunciation which one should you
choose think a bit outside of the Jade
box here and take the lead of this Han
scribe his solution is elegant don't
choose one use both systems together
what's that behind his back is that a oh
yeah
major moments in the history of writing
so here's the logo graph for horse but
it also sounds the same as the word for
ant so the rebus principle lets us write
them both with the same glyph confusing
not if you add the logo graph for insect
next to the sound-alike character this
says it's pronounced like horse which it
is but that its meaning has something to
do with insect you don't read the extra
character it's a meaning hint
determining how to read the sound
character so it's called a determinative
one more Mandarin example this logo
graph means moon which happens to be
pronounced ua using rebus writing ua
also means amputate your feet
incidentally the word key is pronounced
the same way same problem but nothing a
couple determinatives can't fix add the
determinate for metal to this character
add knife to that one and let's leave
the moon be because that's already what
it means here again the sounds like
reading of a character gives you its
phonetic component this extra logograph
Clues you into its meaning its semantic
component together they form a unit a
whole character with a clear meaning and
a clear pronunciation determinative ZAR
very common in Chinese characters
natively called Han characters in fact
since they hint at the characters root
meaning its radix Homme determinatives
get called radicals bringing back the
characters son it can be pronounced in
many ways true but at a determinative a
silent helper character and you can
quickly narrow down its meaning these
extra determinatives avoid ambiguous
readings which one is the Sun in the sky
which is a father son which one means
soon too easy there's something else to
learn from this quiet scribe he's using
radicals to clean up some ambiguity but
even he knows that context matters
he won't spell everything out for you
every time sometimes this character
means for as in this is for you
other times it's the verb supply he's
balancing this tension in the history of
writing between what's easy on the
reader who needs more information to
interpret the words versus what's easy
on the writer who typically knows what
he means when he's writing it
plus hand cramps the choice of leaving
in or leaving out helpful information
isn't simply about clarity and laziness
its aesthetic throughout the history of
Chinese calligraphy from oracle bones to
the rough cursive script stylistic
choices are made not just semantics and
phonetic choices seeing through the
calligraphers eyes you can find in the
history of writing not only a vision of
what words and sounds look like but
where words and sounds go and where they
stop when it comes to aesthetic choices
and Han characters none is more
fundamental than the decision to arrange
character components in blocks bonus
note this is definitely not the only
time in history that writing gets
organized in blocks so this radical sits
on top of this phonetic component in a
block making up one whole character the
character for flower the ideograph man
plus tree a man leaning against a tree
has two components sitting side by side
in a block and there the character for
rest and here's one tree in its own
block two trees meaning woods and three
trees for forest aesthetics aside what
would happen if we took this sounds like
principle a step further and made
writing about the sounds isn't that a
better solution to our soon Sun sown Sun
problem and one that doesn't make us
memorise tons of characters
you